first tonight breaking today extremely
troubling rhetoric from the president of
the united states
if you are one of millions of americans
who disagree
with the radical policies put forth by
the democratic party
watch out because joe biden well he
referred his political opponents today
referred to them as
domestic enemies where's the media that
got so upset
when donald trump said the media is an
enemy of the people because they lie
and tell fake news anyway saying they're
working to subvert
american democracy in a set of prepared
remarks this wasn't off the cuff
better suited for a despotic socialist
dictator frankly
joe biden said that our country is
facing its most significant test
since the civil war echoing gensake
because
all state legislatures why they're
requiring voter i.d
like his state standardized early voting
chain of custody integrity and
verification for
all ballots and now according to whoever
wrote joe's speech
any republican that supports integrity
laws
so we can have competence in election
results is what an enemy of the state
and of course joe biden as always
invoking jim crow once again
take a watch 21st century
jim crow assault is real it's
unrelenting
there's an unfolding assault
taking place in america today an attempt
to suppress and subvert
the right to vote and fair and free
elections
an assault on democracy an assault on
liberty
i swore no to you to god
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution
and that's an oath that forms a sacred
trust
to defend america against all threats
both foreign and
domestic the assault on free and fair
elections
is just such a threat literally i've
said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
most significant tests since the civil
war it's not hyperbole
it's a civil war okay according to that
bizarre speech
anyone that supports basic voter
integrity laws
is pretty much un-american unless of
course you're a democrat like joe
to that end joe biden is now empowering
his department of justice he's
weaponizing them frankly
attorney general merrick garland is
currently suing the state of georgia
over their new voter laws but he's not
suing joe biden's home state of delaware
that he's represented about 5 000 years
which are far more restrictive
there's far less access take a look at
your st your
your screen georgia they allow 17 days
to actually mandate 17 days
of early in-person voting delaware
has no in-person early voting in georgia
anyone could vote absentee you're right
in delaware
no you've got to give an excuse and meet
specific requirements
in georgia drop boxes for absentee
ballots they're available
at county election offices all over the
state
it's mandated delaware has zero drop
boxes for absentee ballots
both states require voter id
joe never lifted a finger to make voting
more accessible
in delaware and it's not just delaware
wisconsin requires voter id rhode island
requires photo id hawaii
you actually have to recite your date of
birth and address in oregon
residents who don't vote regularly you
can be automatically canceled from the
voter rolls
in connecticut minnesota new york voters
must meet certain requirements in order
to vote
absentee unlike georgia none of these
deep blue states are facing a lawsuit
from this now emboldened weaponized
doj of joe biden not one clearly the
left's hysteria over georgia
and now texas has nothing to do at all
in any way
about civil rights it is beyond
hyperbole it's destructive
they're playing the race card oh this is
this is the worst challenge to our
democracy since the civil war
really then why joe have you never
lifted a finger
in the decades and decades frankly
centuries it seems
that you've served your state of
delaware you never lifted a finger
merrick garland where's your integrity
why are
you suing joe stated delaware
that has far more restrictive laws than
in the great state of georgia
and by the way everything to do with
what i can only think of the only reason
you don't want voter id signature
verification
chain of custody controls partisan
observers observing
and cleaning up the voter rolls has got
to have nefarious intentions
i would think this is a non-political
issue so ask yourself why aren't
democrats worried about ballot
harvesting
and election fraud and integrity in our
vote
so every american can have confidence in
our results
now tonight joe actually accidentally
answered that question out loud
because according to biden it's not just
about access to voting but also
who gets to count the votes hmm
it's very interesting take a look
it's no longer just about who gets to
vote or making it
easier for eligible voters to vote it's
about who gets to
count the vote who gets to count whether
or not
your vote counted at all
that's why i want partisan observers on
all side to watch the count start to
finish
if democrats get their way these far
left bureaucrats
in d.c well i guess they'll be counting
those votes
writing every election law literally
usurping
the constitutional power of state
legislatures
that's what hr and sr1 has always been
about
it has nothing to do with voting rights
everything to do with centralized power
and frankly the nefarious motives of
democrats that think the only way they
can win
is to have no checks and balances
democratic swamp
they want control of everything the
left's argument that minorities and
rural voters as kamala harris suggested
yesterday
oh they they just don't have access to
they may not be smart enough
to get a photo id or register to vote is
complete and total
bs and quite frankly it is insulting
beyond insulting to millions of
americans
and that's not stopping kamala harris
from going on national tv
perpetuating this argument in the worst
most despicable way frankly possible
take a look is agreeing to voter id
one of those compromises that you'd
support i don't think that we
should underestimate
what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um xerox are
photocopy your idea to send it in to
prove you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinkos there's no officemax near them
you can make the accommodations really
kamala now of course
a large majority of americans including
59 percent of african americans they
believe photo id requirements
do not discriminate against certain
voters in addition to photo id
what are the important things here we
talk about them all
often and every state should adopt these
are top five
and that is if you want integrity in our
elections confidence in the results
photo id signature verification chain of
custody integrity
voter roll updates for every election
and
partisan observers that means democrats
republicans independents green
party libertarians they all should be
allowed to have observers
from every political side to watch the
counting
up close start to finish the state of
texas is now attempting to implement
similar protections but in order to well
block that vote democratic state leaders
they're
leaving texas in order to prevent a
quorum
in the state house see them in there
they're in that plane right there
i don't see any masks either uh the very
same democrats that called the
filibuster and a front to democracy
they got on their private jet without a
mask they set off for one big expensive
vacation in washington d.c
to temporarily prevent a vote make no
mistake these images perfectly
encapsulate the modern democratic
leftist new green deal party
the rules do not apply to them the only
thing that really matters
is their status centralized power right
there in the swamp
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else